laissez pas de se remplissez à nouveau
dans mon année il dit que c'est pas lui
c'était forcément l'un de vous
non qu'est-ce qu'il fabrique je me gare
en parallèle parallèle à quoi vous
amusez pas de laisser ce rap pisser à
nouveau dans mon aller l'écoute pas il
sait pas qui fait ça c'était forcément
l'un de vous excuse-moi d'arriver en
retard tout le quartier paraolo en ce
moment ça ne tourne pas rond quand t'es
pas là
[Musique]
tu me manques
j'y vais en noir et blanc avant de
rencontrer Sonia veux-tu m'épouser
elle était la couleur
vous prenez les autres pour des critères
et vous croyez de voir tout gérer tout
seul vous avez tort
ça n'y arrive pas
[Musique]
j'aime pas voir un crétin apprendre à
quelqu'un à tenir à volant le centre de
conduite
je vous présente notre ami hop
j'ai failli lui rentrer dedans
mon père souriait comme ça lui aussi je
ne suis pas